chorégraphie spéciale des deux pour les
handballeurs de saran qui viennent de
s'ouvrir les portes du monde
professionnel
la saison a débuté par une victoire à
istres l'idéal serait de confirmer sur
ce premier match à domicile pour rester
dans cette spirale positive
c'est une belle histoire c'est vrai que
moi ils me font vibrer je suis je suis
un passionné ça fait 20 heures un peu
plus de votants que c'est aux clubs et
donc oui je suis je suis assez fier et
je suis content que ça puisse se
prolonger
et pourquoi pas dans quelques années les
voir encore au dessus joueurs et
entraîneurs d'autres sont ouvertes da
costa connaît les joies de la montée est
ce que ça implique un budget revu à la
hausse 900000 euros cette saison et un
recrutement conséquent vous connaissiez
peut-être la force de frappe de
jean-jacques ac vélo vous allez
découvrir celle de tommy vos apps
sans oublier le spécialiste du penalty
nature ou en 11 saisons dans l'élite et
un projet de reconversion dans vos rêves
c'est ce qui m'a vraiment poussé à
signer ici mais je regrette absolument
pas parce que il ya un groupe qui est
enfin déjà l'année dernière c'est un
groupe vraiment super et avec des
valeurs énormes et je pense qu'on peut
faire de belles choses
un groupe solide et solidaire qui a
longtemps fait course en tête face à
sélestat l'un des favoris du championnat
à dix minutes de la fin les saranais
compté quatre buts d'avancé mais à ce
niveau le moindre relâchement la moindre
erreur peuvent être lourds de
conséquences
les alsaciens reviennent au score et
souffle la victoire 31 30
le métier qui rentre
faut essayer de positiver après une
soirée comme ça c'est dur maintenant
dans une demi heure on se dira voilà on
les a fait douter et on n'est pas en d2
par hasard on a des choses à faire
valoir et puis encore une fois je
parlais d'un peu d'apprentissage
d'expérience va peut-être que dans
quelque temps on arrivera à tuer ces
matches est pas passé une mauvaise
mauvais début de soirée gyan défaite
amère mais la sensation d'être à sa
place dans ce championnat
saran peut aussi compter sur ses
supporters on remet ça dès vendredi
la fête ne fait que commencer